[Music]  this is the mossy frog  a tiny amphibian found predominantly  within the flooded caves of northern  vietnam's forests  its main mode of defense  you're looking at it  the mossy frog's skin is a blotchy green  and brown a perfect color match for the  mossy environment it's found in if  threatened it will curl up and play dead  to hide from possible predators  they are semi-aquatic and the  suction-like discs at the end of its  toes make it an agile climber when out  of the water  [Music]  for food they are opportunistic meaning  they'll feed on anything available to  them as their habitat goes through  constant change  one change in particular is the recent  deforestation of northern vietnam's  forests  as the forests have become smaller so  has the mossy frog's population landing  them on the endangered species list  this is the mossy frog  [Music]  you